and with a major development the
investigation into the death of George
Floyd that was a reaction in Minneapolis
yesterday afternoon after the new
charges were announced against all four
X police officers we got all four
they're saying connected to Floyd's
death which was a major demand of the
protesters former officers to tau J
Alexander King and Thomas Lane are all
in custody this morning on charges of
aiding and abetting murder
Anthony former officer Derek shavon is
now accused of second-degree murder
which carries a stiffer penalty than the
charges he was already facing Jeff
Pegues has been covering the story from
Minneapolis where he spoke with Floyd's
brother and family attorney Jeff how are
they reacting to this well Anthony the
family is relieved they wanted to see
these increased charges they wanted to
see all of the officers arrested and
charged and they wanted to see those mug
shots family attorney Benjamin Crump
called yesterday a tipping point for
justice we have to have justice they
murdered him and broad daylight in front
of everybody
for George Floyd's brother felonious
justice doesn't stop at arrests and an
upgraded charge he believes Derek shavon
knew what he was doing and should face
the most serious charge of first-degree
murder when you look at that guy when he
was on his neck and big was pleading for
her life like please please just let him
breathe get off of him get off of him he
was just looking at them like they was
in a cage or something like you can't
get to me in announcing the decision
yesterday Minnesota Attorney General
Keith Allison said the charges are the
first step he asked the public for their
confidence even though history has shown
the challenges of prosecuting police
officers every single link in the
prosecutorial chain must be strong it
needs to be strong because trying this
case will not be an easy thing winning a
conviction
will be hard but attorney Benjamin Crump
believes the video will make it clear to
any juror are you sort of putting the
cart before the horse raising
expectations because this is a tough
case we have an expectation of justice
we can never stop believing that we will
get equal justice but do you really
think you will in this I believe we
would get a conviction in this can you
do
I absolutely do this video is horrific
the initial complaint against Eric
shavon sheds light on what happened the
day George Floyd was killed
according to the complaint Officer
Thomas Lane asked shavon if they should
roll Floyd on his side after Floyd said
he couldn't breathe several times
shavon answered no staying put where we
got him one minute after Floyd became
unresponsive Lane again said I want to
roll him on his side
officer cung then checked for a pulse
and said I couldn't find one
Floyd son Quincy Mason was thankful
after the charges were filed I am happy
that all the officer be arrested
my father had not been killed like this
we deserve justice at the sight of
George Floyd's memorial and at protests
across Minneapolis news of the new
arrests spread quickly
hundreds of protesters chanted many with
their fists raised in the air with the
charges behind them with felonious just
wants everyone to remember his big
brother everybody loves them kids and
all that's my big brother
my oldest brother now instead being
oldest president one of the key
witnesses and any of these upcoming
trials is going to be the passenger who
was in Floyd's car we haven't heard a
lot about him but his name is Maurice
Lester Hall he talked to the New York
Times and what he told them yesterday
was that he did not see Floyd resisting
arrest and that's key because initially
police said that Floyd resisted arrest
and that's what led to happen to what
happened here behind me there's going to
be a memorial service and it starts
later on today Anthony Jeff began